[Music]
hi sweetheart I know how eager you are
to be married but maybe that's not your
calling come on I want this trial of
Sandra's probably like daydreaming about
some guy that's gonna magically come to
take her away from here
did you just smile you I don't know why
is he smiling who is that oh no
attention everyone
sister Fernanda sister Alejandra sister
Maria
is he your sins bling-bling [ __ ] do my
own thing [ __ ] piece of language but I
mean they called me a joke lustfulness
homosexuality tiny Jew your eyes your
ring ring wake up lil [ __ ] let me
show you how to live - its left with
another man's wife one of these [ __ ]
thinks he's quite logistic crazy for you
little [ __ ] did you hear what Stan's
drunken be tough I'm not gonna lie they
can be very tough why this [ __ ] this is
a Turner okay physically attacked people
respect masturbating wing [ __ ] to my
own things true that you've never been
touched by man no never it's the
greatest pleasure when I'm looking out
for my mama and my fav one [ __ ]
immortal Sonny when get into heaven
yeah then you probably shouldn't the
long list I've ever had apostasy visa
bling with Kerastase reveling eating
blood do you think I've ever written
down to meeting blood before where am I
bling bling
[Music]
you
[Music]
beautiful morning sister
hey don't [ __ ] you talk so I love it
again pressing a brother-sister Fernanda
sister Alessandra sister Mariana give
you your sins
bling-bling [ __ ] do my own thing [ __ ]
filthy conversations buy your own
[ __ ] business Lost Levels
homosexuality tiny your honor no you're
wrong right
wake up lil [ __ ] let me show you how
to live a really beautiful job when they
have goddamn balls recently little [ __ ]
did you hear what I said girls can be
tough I'm not gonna lie they can be very
tough why this [ __ ] is eternity
tournament [ __ ] not fair you're just
stuck here with all these amazing [ __ ]
my own thing I've slept with another
man's wife sometimes she would place her
mouth around my sexy looks solid
I thought of me which is I went someone
with an ax trader we're also something
right did you do that I I did
so walk with the other hand impossible
to abusive language caressed a trembling
eating blood do you think I've ever
written down the median blood before
where am I bling bling [ __ ] do my own
thing [ __ ] buckle wedding bring that
ding-a-ling a linguist discipling [ __ ]
you